- Obviously, these guys are known
for going all out to prank one another.
They had so many awesome stories,
we couldn't fit it all in
when it originally aired.
So check out this previously
unseen part of our interview,
when they shared some of their
latest and greatest pranks.
All I can say is, these
guys are super creative.
- The guys also got me a few weeks ago.
I came home,
and they had in my backyard,
a doctor
put a catheter in me,
and then they had my wife
who was a junior in nursing,
take it out of me.
And then they had another doctor
give me a prostate exam
all in my backyard,
while I had to Zipline.
(laughter)
- What?
- All on a regular Tuesday.
- Oh my gosh. This is like,
this is like the worst hazing ever,
like, oh my God.
- Kelly, this is why we love you.
It's like, you're the
fifth impractical joker.
What's your home address?
- [Kelly] Hell no.
Hell no. You know what?
I'm going to give somebody
else's address I don't like.
I'm gonna pick, I'm
gonna give that address.
Wait, but what happened
at Murr's apartment?
- Oh, that was another, so we,
we made Murray do a battle of wits,
against a fifth grader.
And it was like, we set
up like a game show.
Every time the fifth grader
won the trivia question,
we would remove something
from Murray's home,
but from his apartment back then.
But what it was is we didn't
just take like, the couch.
We took things that were fixed.
So we took like his,
like his shower head,
all of his fixtures from his door.
We actually took the front door.
- What?
- We took all of his,
all of his appliances.
We just removed all the things
that he couldn't replace.
So he couldn't even,
I don't think Murr, you
couldn't even, like,
you had no door that night, right?
You went to bed without
a door, a front door.
- I had no door and this was a rental.
I didn't own it.
So I had to pay the building
several thousand dollars to
replace literally the faucets,
the handles, the door
handle in my apartment.
- What? What? How? How?
That's like a Dateline
special waiting to happen PS
But, what, how long did you
go without those things?
- I had to fork over the money,
to have maintenance replace them.
It's on me. I should have
answered the trivia right,
and we wouldn't have had this problem.
- Oh my gosh. Oh my gosh, y'all are-
what now?
- The grand prize for the game show was,
he won Murray's actual diploma
from Georgetown university.
So, the kid,
he got to pick anything he
wanted in James's apartment.
And he took his diploma off his wall,
and it's hanging in this
fifth grader's house.
- [Murr] Could have chosen an X-Box,
he could have chosen a VR headset.
He went with my Georgetown
university's diploma,
that little son of a gun.
- Wait,
did one of you tell him to do
it or did he just naturally,
that's just what he went for today.
- We suggested.
- You suggested it! You guys are so wrong.
Oh my god.
I have no idea how- y'all
should make like a re-enactment,
like you should do a grumpy old man,
and dress up as older men
and do a movie it's insane.
I don't know how y'all are still friends.
So wait, what happened with Prince Herb?
It was something with a seminar.
- Oh. So Prince Herb had
lost a while ago, and he,
we made him present a seminar,
on how to remove stress from his life.
And so Prince Herb was up there,
and he had never seen the videos,
that were in part of the presentation.
So as he hit play on the next slide,
we had unbeknownst to Prince
Herb talk to Prince Herb's mom,
Queen Herb.
(laughing)
And we said, hey, can
we borrow the house key?
And we broke into his house,
and we did things like roll around on his,
like on his furniture in the buck.
Murray took a shower and,
and ate the peanut butter
right out with the finger.
- I don't know if you know
this about Prince Herb,
he doesn't like cats.
So I got a new kitten that week
and brought it over to
Prince Herb's house,
and let the kitten run around
his bed in his pillows,
and stuff like that.
So, Prince Herb had a great
night's sleep that night.
- They stormed my castle.
- Prince Herb.
- [Kelly] They stormed my castle.
It is amazing that
y'all are still friends.
I'm just going to keep reiterating it.